hugs some people love them some people
hate them but what is it deal with them
the word ha comes from a Saxon word that
means to be tender of scientists have
also observed hugging in Apes as a form
of greeting I myself love hugging and it
has been scientifically proven that hugs
will add 10 to 30 years to your life
just kidding and I but they do help a
study that exposed 404 healthy adults to
a common cold found that subjects who
receive hugs before and during the cold
experience less of your symptoms it is
presumed that hugs lower their stress
level and making them less vulnerable as
it turns out a 2014 study found that
physical touch could help protect from
stress induced sickness there's a broad
amount of evidence suggesting that
social support has a positive influence
on health in a hug receptors on your
skin can signal unnerve receptor on the
brain called the vagus nerve not to be
confused with this the vagus nerve has
branches that connect to the heart and
is responsible for slowing down its
beating and if that's not enough
embraces such as hugging may also
release endorphins that counteract
stress and depression in fact not having
affectionate touch in early development
can decrease a person's ability to be
intimate or compassionate so huggy kids
so hug away I'll get everyone hug you
cousin your friend your mom your uncle
your coworker hug everybody if you want
to live the long and healthy life but
definitely ask first
consent is important
[Applause]
[Music]
you